j'ai vu coincer mais mentalement c'est
vrai coin
il a mis de l'argent mais attendez le
débat citoyen du quartier sainte-thérèse
a commencé timidement est un peu en
retard mais au final une quarantaine de
personnes a fait le déplacement
profitant de cet espace d'expression et
du cadre du grand débat national
chacun a pu formuler des constats et des
propositions parfois très différents ça
bien qu'à écouter moon s'habiller comme
on parlait parce qu'un pagne à bâbord
avant d'animer des mines endormies le
monde va des gabarits a besoin n'est pas
célébrée au profit des bons rapports
je vis en métropole alors je suis
l'actualité de très près et je suis venu
je suis en vacances jusqu'au 11 mars
je suis venu parce que ça m'intéresse
comme ça doit intéresser tout citoyen
qui se considèrent tél moi j'ai envie
que ça a mis l'eau et ib parce que le
n'oublie garden où est vraiment rigoler
mais pas garanti car marché et nous et
donc à diminuer en l'agent ces retraités
à sa part ça pas fait non plus pour
mieux rendre compte de la teneur du
débat des notes sont prises en temps
réel elles sont affichées sur grand
écran et servent aussi à alimenter les
échanges
elles seront remonter ensuite vers la
préfecture hier soir il y avait surtout
un public averti composé de membres du
tissu associatif et politique locale
nous les forts aujourd'hui c'est d'aller
chercher d'autres personnes et de
permettre l'expression ce soit possible
pour tous c'est en fait le problème
c'est simplement que souvent il ya des
référents il ya des associations qui
sont habitués au débat public et qu'ils
s'approprient l'avantagé de débats bien
d'autres personnes là qui parle si vous
faites attention vous allez voir qu'il
ya aussi bien d initier des personnes
qui sont
responsables associatifs des gens qui
sont habitués et puis on a d'autres qui
viennent avec leurs émotions avec leurs
expressions et le débat se fait
rappelons que le site internet de la
ville ainsi qu'un cahier en mairie
permettent également de recueillir les
doléances et quatre autres débats sont
prévus les 29 et 30 janvier a dit
l'oncle chateauboeuf et les 4 et 5
février à gaudissart puis à la mairie de
fort-de-france